[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es el jefe de
gabinete adjunto el presidente de
ucrania volodymyr selenski nos acompaña
desde kiev muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros
gracias por recibirme señor sopka
empecemos con las situaciones mariupol
que es lo último que ha pasado
desafortunadamente la situación no está
mejorando
a pesar de las promesas del presidente
putin de no atacar la planta siderúrgica
de as hostal donde todavía hay personas
fuerzas armadas ucranianas civiles
ucranianos y soldados ucranianos heridos
de lyon el lugar sigue bajo ataque y
desafortunadamente esas personas no
pueden ser evacuadas
a través de los corredores humanitarios
el presidente sugirió un intercambio de
soldados ucranianos heridos y de civiles
por soldados rusos heridos
desafortunadamente no hubo reacción
las personas de la ciudad de mariupol
los civiles tampoco están siendo
evacuados
hay más de 100.000 civiles en todo el
territorio de mariupol y casi todos los
días tratamos de establecer corredores
humanitarios
pero los bombardeos continúan la ciudad
ha sido prácticamente arrasada no hay un
solo edificio que esté afectado las
personas están viviendo en condiciones
terribles sin electricidad sin
suministro de alimentos sin agua las
situaciones móviles
no podemos desbloquear la ciudad usando
medios militares porque no tenemos
suficiente artillería ni armas
así que la única manera de tener una vía
humanitaria es a través de las
negociaciones de los corredores algo que
mi presidente sigue sugiriendo todos los
días
pero desafortunadamente no ha habido una
respuesta positiva por parte de rusia
quieren que mario posea una victoria
simbólica para ellos tienen que ser
rinda pero la mariupol ucraniana nunca
se va a rendir
los rusos están haciendo algún progreso
desde que lanzaron su operación en
bombas
ha pasado casi más de una semana como lo
ve usted
el poder principal todavía se está
reagrupando y podrían empezar su
ofensiva en cualquier momento
ahora tienen proyectiles de artillería
en toda la línea de contacto
de prácticamente todo el territorio de
combate
aparte de eso están tratando de hacer
una ofensiva de trabajo dejar que
desde la ciudad de ciu para tratar de
rodear a las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
en el donbass
pero nosotros tenemos a uno de los
mejores y más experimentados ejércitos
porque han luchado contra esta agresión
rusa desde 2014 cuando rusia realmente
empezó su agresión contra ucrania con la
toma de partes ucranianas de bombas
así que tienen mucha experiencia pero no
están bien equipados en este caso una
vez más necesitamos la mayor cantidad
posible de armas y mansiones de otros
países
apreciaríamos que francia y otros
miembros de la unión europea nos ayuden
con algo de armamento
nuclear y recibir una visita simbólica
el domingo y el secretario de estado y
el secretario de defensa de eeuu el
secretario de defensa dijo lo cito
ucrania puede vencer a rusia con el
equipamiento adecuado también hemos
escuchado a su presidente hablar con más
confianza que de costumbre pero que
cambió recientemente y
que cambió la voluntad de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianos creo que eso es lo
que ha sorprendido a todo el mundo
muchos presuntos expertos militares no
le daban más de tres o cuatro días a las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas al comienzo
de la guerra war no ahora llevamos 61
días de guerra y los ucranianos están
luchando las fuerzas ucranianas están
resistiendo los ataques rusos
están recuperando pueblos y ciudades
ucranianas
hemos logrado sacar a los rusos del
norte del país
de los alrededores de kiev
creo que todo el mundo está gratamente
sorprendido por la fuerza y la voluntad
moral de las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
y el mito sobre el supuesto segundo
ejército más fuerte del mundo
el ejército ruso
definitivamente se ha evaporado en
ucrania
con las armas que necesitamos podremos
ganar esta guerra pero no necesitamos
cualquier tipo de armas
necesitamos armas concretas en el
terreno con los sistemas de artillería y
lanzacohetes múltiples vehículos
blindados antes y también necesitamos
armas para defender el espacio aéreo
como sistemas antimisiles y aviones de
combate que no lee así que sólo puede
estar de acuerdo con las palabras del
señor hosting se habló con el presidente
recientemente francia también ha enviado
armas más sofisticadas
el presidente francés y manuel marco
acaba de ser reelegido
ahora que estas elecciones han terminado
espera que puedan llegar más armas
sofisticadas a ucrania
el presidente felicitó de manera formal
al presidente marc con apenas informaron
los primeros resultados de la elección
esta es una gran victoria
seré muy honesto y abierto con usted
esta es una gran victoria para nosotros
en europa no solo para francia
definitivamente para ucrania y para
otros miembros de la unión europea
el pueblo francés tomó una buena y sabia
decisión
definitivamente france está cambiando su
posición de manera positiva respecto al
suministro de armas
así que después de la reelección sin
esta carga política de la campaña
[Música]
esperamos que su presidente sea aún más
fuerte y más activo en suministrarle
ucrania las armas sofisticadas y pesadas
que necesitamos como
en apoyar la oposición de la unión
europea con sanciones más estrictas
contra la federación rusa incluyendo la
energía en apoyar a los ucranianos para
su integración europea
que mi país necesita con urgencia la
condición de candidato en julio
y realmente esperamos que el presidente
marco con su sabiduría y su voluntad web
y al ser impulsor de la integración
europea
apoye esta ideas y pueda convencer a sus
socios de la unión europea
espera que él pueda convencer a alemania
el aliado más cercano de francia en
europa
y que envía armamento pesado a su país y
que también acepte un embargo de
petróleo por parte de la unión europea
porque hasta el momento alemania se ha
negado a hacerlo
y
realmente espero que con su ejemplo con
sus acciones pueda convencer al líder
alemán
y presidente habla de manera constante
con el canciller souls y la posición de
alemania está cambiando tal vez un poco
más despacio no tan rápido como
podríamos esperar pero si francia
convence a alemania de que nos ayude con
un armamento pesado y con las sanciones
es muy importante que en el sexto
paquete de sanciones al menos el
petróleo esté presente
el petróleo y los productos derivados
del petróleo
pero sin sanciones contra el petróleo
ruso este sexto paquete será inútil
no necesitamos el paquete en sí mismo
necesitamos sanciones concretas que
afecten inmediatamente la economía rusa
when it ken griffey jr sans
si sé que eso podría ser difícil para
los países europeos
pero de un lado están las posibles
consecuencias negativas para sus países
y del otro está en las vidas de los
ucranianos mueren por cada euro que se
gana gracias a los países europeos
e inmediatamente lo gasté en la
industria militar para producir más
misiles balísticos
aviones de combate que matan civiles
ucranianos madres ucranianas
niños civiles
ya todos los granjeros
así que esperamos el liderazgo del
presidente mac con este sentido
su presidente dice que sigue abierto a
reunirse con vladimir putin
pero parece que los diálogos entre
ucrania y rusia no están llevando a
ninguna parte
más allá de decir que habrá diálogos
computing y hay alguna esperanza de que
esto ocurra
sin importar lo difícil que sea para mi
presidente y para cualquier funcionario
ucraniano
hablar con los funcionarios rusos
después de que el mundo entero viera las
atrocidades que los cometieron en
boston y por jan carlos el presidente
sigue reiterando que está listo para una
solución diplomática a la guerra con
rusia y
la delegación ucraniana está lista para
proceder con ese trabajo
el problema es que los rusos no están
listos para un verdadero diálogo
diplomático no son para una verdadera
negociación que dé resultados
probablemente están esperando a ver qué
sucede en la batalla de lombáns
están alargando el tiempo para poder
ocupar las posiciones más fuertes
el presidente colom ha dedicado parte de
su tiempo para largo del presidente
puntos para convencerlo de que pare la
guerra así que ya lo veremos
realmente apreciamos lo que el
presidente majones está haciendo y los
esfuerzos de cada líder para que putin
se presente a la mesa de negociación
serán apreciados
lo repito
como conclusión cree que don va a ser el
factor decisivo para saber si esto
terminará de manera militar
o con unas negociaciones
bueno eso lo que entendemos de la
posición rusa para nosotros la batalla
del bombas es la batalla por el
territorio ucraniano
no estamos pensando en términos de
negociación
debemos defender nuestra tierra
las agresiones empezaron desde el
donbass primero no negociaremos un solo
metro de territorio ucraniano
el donbass cochrane no era es y será
siempre ucrania
así que lucharemos estamos luchando por
nuestra propia tierra no necesitamos el
territorio de nadie más pero lucharemos
hasta el final para defender nuestro
territorio
y el soca muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en la entrevista de france 24
muchas gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos 20
[Música]